morning guys all right so doing are
still easy intensity the intensity is
gonna be pretty easy workout up but
we're going to go for 10 minutes so 2
minute warm-up 10 minutes
calisthenics and then probably about a 5
6 minute meditation maybe a little more
like a 6 6 or 7 minute meditation day
all right let's go to work
so the same as before relax the upper
body let the lower body you all work
yeah
so again relax that upper body spot
connection straight lower bodies doing
all the work
I was I
you sinner big breath in reaching up
back forward now hang so relax that
lower spine
ow
keep going behind the back and a lot
fingers because Hannibal chest over down
circle the upper body
other direction
and coming back up release the arms go
in one side remember keep the leg that's
supporting you try and get that heel
down on the ground if you can the other
legs go down right now stretch all
through the groin stretch it all through
on the inside of my thighs another solid
a next low again just put that's 40 and
he'll shoot down that toes down
stretched on the insides of your thighs
back over to up this time sit-outs which
from the inside for thighs the back of
her thighs she'd be getting hamstring
stretch back in the knee area back in
the cab we'll let you be getting
stretched right now toes getting pulled
back actively pulling that toe back
he'll stay on the get on this side
other side ginto up eel down over here
actually pull them up back Toback
you they can we across dropping the
forward knee knee knee knee board never
relax the upper body so I'm rigidly keep
the spine up you're tweaking your hip
more than you need to if you're doing
that right so just relax your hips and
let the stretch happen in your hip
flexor as naturally as it can right so
don't really try to stay super upright
right now just relax let everything
stretching stretching decided
and as I
coming elbows on the knees nice deep
squat if you could squat you can rocking
back and forth as I'm rocking I'm trying
to actively stretch a little bit more as
I'm rocking back and forth in the
Middle's for the feet
and sitting back good nice straight
spine here big breath in raise the arms
turn towards the foot reach down
and that center-right then turn towards
bullet reach towards that foot
and back to Center both feet together
big breath in reaching forward reaching
forward trying to keep that spine nice
and straight we do this try not to
overly round your shoulders or hunter
backs up straight spine you can make or
reach into those toes
and breathe in good use the elbows push
the knees actively down so I want those
needs to be down it's glad you can
possibly be dropping a chest I'm
dropping the chest straight spine
right on brown your spine so as we're
dropping the chest so we're like this
right keep the spine streets it can be
as you're dropping that chest that's
like your belly's trying to hit your
feet your chest is trying to hit the
ground so my chest is going here and my
battle is going here don't make your
yeah we love the stomach and right
underneath the shoulders and breathing
in and up nice
Cobra hips are trying to push work the
ground ball my head is rocking back over
my head to come back we head straight
and make a big circle out of my body you
feel looking majority of the stretch in
your stomach and not in your back so not
holding your shining head your spine
reaching the nice big arc for is getting
stretch good down I'm going to both the
feet push the hips straight back if
you're going back my heels are you push
towards the ground I'm really trying to
push my feels worth crap stretching it
really well my knees all actively with
my shoulders
your wrist stretches first ones code of
guys so palm towards my face are you
trying to grab the base of my thumb turn
the thumb towards you guys you'll turn
your thumb towards me
then we're gonna sink our hand down you
can get a big stretch and you sink that
hand down two hands already turned over
all the way once you start sinking it
down it's gonna get tight does it cook
the guy just means risk reversal cook
Thais wrist literally means a little
hand and I see what kite means to flip
something over to reverse something like
a pancake pancake
other side home towards the face they
trying to get the base of the thumb sink
the hand totally down cook the guys
well we went slower on our stretches
than it does where you keep doing over
him up I'm gonna get all the way through
this one up today all right other side
sungkyu of a palm towards me so you're
gonna stick your palm towards me my
palms toward you we're turning up the
base the index finger thumb towards me
push the hand to the side some kill
Sonya's three kill is principle or
lesson so it's the third principle in
Aikido
and the other side palm up your palms
facing me your anger up the base of your
index finger turn the strength to thumb
the thumb is out at which they had to
decide some kill third principle as
you're doing this you should feel the
stretch in your wrist of course you
should also feel in your elbow and your
shoulder X I'm linking all the way
through my body wrist elbow shoulder
good making a ring with the index finger
and the thumb place that ring flat on
the palm of your hand pull your hands
back elbows forward fingers are pointing
at you your finger should be pointing at
me elbows pushing forward the more you
push your your fingers forward and then
elbows forward the triger the stretch is
going to become so the side of my hands
flat on the side of my other hand or the
palm momentum and other way ring put
that ring flat on the palm of your hand
pull your hands back elbows go forward
fingers pointing at me just want your
fingers right at me elbows right at me
this is me kill me is to kill its
principal second principle in Aikido and
pulling the fingers back this is Yahoo
gokyo gokyo is the fifth principle and
it's folding the wrist down this is
extending the wrist or flexing the wrist
out and this the gap with it the
opposite of the folding down just Jacopo
and other side Tokyo
going longer on this warm-up than I
should but I want to get the whole one
down because as we start to increase
intensity levels we're gonna change our
warmups I want to get the whole one down
today
good stretch out there check out the
wrists and the arms so really work on
relaxing your elbows and your wrists
when you're doing this back and forth
bring the arm across the chest pull it
in nice and tight
other side
a my head really looking up with the
heads that way we stretched that really
nice so I'm feeling the stretch all
along the back of my arm tricep shoulder
ever in the back of my arms feeling that
and other side
and down yeah all right coming up so
we're gonna go through the Indian
wrestler warm-up today so I don't know
if it's true or not but supposedly being
Restless or amazingly strong people get
strong by doing mainly two exercises
which is squat variation and a push up
variation we're going to do those now so
first squat or leave our spine nice and
straight we need 10 of these guys we're
gonna hold our throw arms back and squat
down and drag the ground we're going to
pull our arms straight back when we get
up so drag the ground back up that's two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
real simple all right now push up
variation up in the air push down back
and scoop out like this so yeah back to
back that's three down back that's for
EM back that's five down
back yeah all right back door squats
1 2 3 4 5 6
seven eight nine ten
one two three
by back our swaps moving three sets of
these guys one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten push-ups
what you
three
ah good job so that combination is
really good to just work
he's made me apparently Indian
restaurant to do like hundred of those
to warm up you know 100 squats hundred
push-ups on day all right so the core
work eight meters
other side
bicycle
the direction
together pull them out and sit up down
heat up down sit it up now heat up down
sit up down heat up down sit up now get
up down sit up hold the position good
yeah no feet up on the side go up your
leg side to side if this is hard for you
make your knees so this is easier you
want to challenge the straight your legs
together let your feet separated
could you
your job under stomach okay with a
regular pushup position forward lean so
we're going to hold the position back
yeah it's like like good a nice position
by stray bullet
yeah
outside technique basic position he can
do this up I'm going to your elbow
job all right guys grab some water okay
okay okay meditation time now you've
worked out what stuff's gonna be in your
head let that stuff go right so we're
just gonna be present now that's the
idea so be right now in the moment if
you go down a rabbit hole meaning you
know like whoa what am I gonna have for
breakfast
hope it's a breakfast burrito don't go
down the rabbit hole too far
second you catch yourself going down a
rabbit hole just stop stop whatever the
thought is right so it's easier it
actually is all right guys
three locks of the Bell in three not to
the bail out the door by the way it's
already warm all right here we go
[Music]
alright guys good job so remember we're
doing the meditation it's the same as
the physical workout is for our body the
meditation is for our mind so in Aikido
it's not good enough to just have a
strong body we need to have a strong
mind also and strong mind means that I
have total control over my mind right
meaning that I can use my conscious mind
is its intended to use my subconscious
super conscious mind all the different
parts of my mind I can use them as
they're as there's meant to be used and
that would be motion right so where I'm
working in this natural state in my my
conscious mind is not trying to actively
override everything okay guys that is it
thanks for joining me today I'll see you
on Thursday at 7 a.m.
good jump